by the way I played Arena
uh
so that that was uh of course attained
um
legally as one does alternate means by
alternate means right uh on floppy on
floppy disks and that was um
that was such an incredible as as you as
you probably have seen interacted with a
large number of people it's a whole
world it's a world that you escape to in
the way like your favorite book like
Lord of the Rings
you it was just some it was um
it was unlike anything else it was
incredible it's probably I mean of
course as people say it's the first game
you play is the most uh is the one that
really sentimentally means the most to
you that's I think the first
role-playing game I played and it was
just changed everything was Arena it was
Arena yeah I think Daggerfall is what I
really kind of really played
um especially because like you said the
character development was really rich
but just like that you can uh be feel
like you traveled to this whole other
world that's less about entertainment
like a shooting game right and more
bottle World it felt like it's a world
like like uh like you're literally there
you can travel there you can live there
you actually feel like that person
versus like a Pac-Man like um
like an arcade fun entertaining event
adventure game